it's scary being in a
locked space or a you know an enclosed
space with someone
that's struggling like that having
someone that can fall down the stairs or
has breathing issues um you know you're
constantly scared that they're gonna die
naomi's dad is alcohol and drug
dependent
he has bounced between sobriety and
traumatic behavior her whole life
but this second national lockdown has
exacerbated his addictions
i mean january february for anyone with
mental health issues is really hard
anyway
and i think all the small things that
gave shape to his life
have now been stripped away he had a
relapse on
first of jan and it's kind of been
ongoing since then
with hospital admissions and two
hospital admissions
an overdose
yeah and you just sort of can't see the
end i think
it's the hopelessness of it and there's
not an end point
addiction is an illness in isolation and
when the entire country is cocooned in
lockdown
it gives the most perilous of issues
space to thrive
a survey of the families of substance
users shows that since the first
lockdown 85 of families have struggled
more with helping their loved one
almost half witnessed increased alcohol
or drug use
another charity says they've seen an 86
rise in the number of people seeking
help this january
compared to last hello everyone but the
help available
looks very different thank you all for
taking the time out of your day too
practitioner katie helps the families of
people with drug and alcohol issues
the anonymity of joining virtual support
groups
can be comforting but some are missing
out
we can't give the front line care
because we are unable to run the
the groups within lockdown we can run
them via zoom sessions
but obviously it doesn't work in the
same way
it doesn't have the same feeling for
people there's not that same level of
support
we can't even offer somebody a cup of
tea and a biscuit if they come to a
support group
which is really key to making people
feel welcome
charities are striving to do better but
resources are limited
there is some help out there i of course
would say there's not enough what we're
doing at ant farm is
campaigning and trying to fundraise so
we can offer more and more help for
these families
but it's still i think we still we're on
a journey and we still have a way to go
naomi's dad is currently in hospital
recovering from his latest overdose
whilst it's respite for her and her mum
they miss him dearly for many the end of
lockdown means renewed freedoms
but for millions with dependency issues
it would also mean stopping this
triggering period
in its tracks ashley harinag sky news
you